how come live in hell get to work
anti-terror Richard Belzer Law and Order
SVU star has died he was 78 years old
there's no single moment it's just that
accumulatively over 300 episodes working
with all the many many directors and all
these great guest stars just as a and as
the entire experience is the greatest
moment according to the Hollywood
Reporter Richard's death came after
suffering from many health issues the
comedian died early Sunday at his home
in France and an official cause of death
has not yet been revealed
victims always hold something back I
hate that usually a detail they're
embarrassed about it's very unusual for
a cast to get along so well for so long
we've always gotten along well from the
beginning but just built and built over
the years and that sounds like a cliche
and corny but we are a family 15 years
is a long time so there's a lot of
camaraderie and family feeling and
support and we've always got each
other's back
Richards SVU co-stars are remembering
him
including Marishka Hargitay who wrote
quote goodbye my dear dear friend I will
miss you your unique light and your
singular take on this strange world
and Chris Maloney sharing his
condolences in part never met anyone
like him and I never will again
stand the big man bowlander Stan the Man
was my mentor in Baltimore just like I
am yours circle of life my friend Circle
of Life Richard starred as Sergeant John
Munch in Law and Order SVU until 2013.
unfortunately most of the stories are
based on reality that you know it's a
astounding what people are capable of
doing to each other and just you know to
make it dramatically viable and
entertaining is what the writers are
good at but a lot of the things you see
on our show and it happened in one way
or another unfortunately he even played
the role for 23 years in total across 12
different TV series it's pretty amazing
for you know a cop show to be more than
just a you know shoot him up so we're
very proud of that
foreign